do you think there will always be war in
the world
is this just a part of human nature
i think so i think
i think it is uh
until we until we move past resource
limitation
there's always going to be at least that
one particular cause
of conflict
and then we can also consider all our
psychological
lizard brain emotions that cause us to
act out although you know we're
hopefully we have enough things in place
to stop that from
rising to the level of war but you know
we have our own biology our own
psychology and evolution to combat
um and then but there are pragmatic
reasons to exert violence sometimes
unfortunately and that one of those
cases could be resource limitations and
so your question was do i think there'll
always be war in this world i
my unfortunate answer is perhaps yes but
once there's more than one world then
we're less resource constrained then
perhaps it'll be a valve of sorts for
that
i talked to
jocko on this podcast i i i told him
about a song
called brothers in arms
by dire straits
and uh the question i asked them i'd
like to ask you the same question is um
like the song goes
do you think we're fools to wage war and
our brothers in arms
and jacob said
our enemy is not our brothers and arms
they're the enemy
and so this kind of notion that we're
all human
that's a notion that's a luxury you can
have
but there is
good and bad in this world according to
jocko i hear that
anger and hate when i
was in ukraine among some people
were
there was a sense where you could be
brothers and sisters you can have family
you can have love
for
from ukraine to russia
but now that everything changed and
generational hate for some people have
taken over
so i guess the question is um
when you think about the enemy
is there hate there you acknowledge that
they're human
i had never had any hate or discontent
you know when i was doing my job i'll
say
but i was also never in a true life or
death
situation where they were gonna kill me
if i didn't kill them
um
but you know i think that environment
isn't one born out of hate
you know being in that type of scenario
you know a sense it's how to be alive
right i mean that's the our natural
state is be fighting for our survival in
a sense and so i think there's there's
great
power and strength and clarity perhaps
in that and it's not always borne out of
of hate but out of necessity and we
can't always control that
and i think as we focus on ourselves so
much
we only dance on that pinhead when we
find ourselves fighting for things that
we need
and we're always taking from someone
else at this point and so
as someone that's been in combat and
very high above it i'll say right where
i didn't feel like i was in particular
danger
um
i i rationalized it and i made my way do
it knowing that there were people on the
other side that were going to die that
were on our side than not so it was
always a very human thing it was never
a reaction emotional reaction of any
sense so you do you were able to see
the basic uh it's human versus human
there's some aspect of war that is
basically
um one people fighting each other
yes
at the end of the day you know
especially i would say in aviation
tactical aviation there's almost a
kinship with your your enemies in a
sense because you know that
you know them in a sense right you know
what they've been through
you know what training they've been
through you know where they've failed
um and you know what type of person they
are because it's a very unique person
that does that job and usually can spot
them i guess it's the kind of respect
you have
for the craftsmanship of the job that's
taken on certainly and that person
didn't come out in his 100 million
dollar jet because i pissed him off you
know it's it's not an emotional response
we're both there
maybe because we chose to be in some
sense but at the behest of of someone
else and outside of our control and
power and so in a sense for me
it's almost a challenge that we've
engaged upon agreeably but that's such a
romantic version that i have the luxury
to have being high in my castle in the
jet up there not on the ground so i
understand that it's a bit more romantic
than perhaps
you know someone on the ground
experiencing all the horrors down there
because everything looks very small from
above
and that's another aspect of war with
greater autonomy when you're controlling
the mission versus
uh
you know
have a genghis khan type of intimacy in
terms of the actual
experience of war where you directly
have
you murder with a sword versus a gun
versus a remotely controlled drone
versus a strategic mission assignment to
an autonomous drone that executes
abstracted away until it's just a small
decision
and my worry
is the people without a voice
are
are completely forgotten and silenced in
all these calculations i spoke to a lot
of people
poor people
that feel like they've never really had
a voice and um
and they're too easily forgotten even
within the country of ukraine
it's the uh
the um
big city versus the rural divide
you know it's easy to forget the people
that
don't have a twitter account and don't
that their basic existence is just
trying to survive trying to put food on
the table and they don't have anything
else
um anything else and they are the ones
that truly feel the pain of war
of uh the supply chain going down or the
food supplies going down of of a cold
winter without power
you